[Music]
kylie jenner and travis scott engage in
some rare pda while their four-year-old
daughter stormy webster dishes out all
the cuteness in a new vlog and it's all
to celebrate baby number two
i thought it would only be right to let
you guys know
that i am 34 weeks today we got to let
him see the belly
34 weeks today which means we only got
about a month left
last month kai and trav welcomed their
second child together a son at the time
a source told et that the two are over
the moon since the arrival of their baby
boy adding that they have wanted to grow
their family and give stormy a sibling
for a while and couldn't be happier i'm
obsessed with it well on monday the new
parents proved all that's true dropping
this 10-minute video documenting their
sweet pregnancy journey including the
moments after they got that positive
pregnancy test
yeah cue the waterworks because that's
the rapper wrapping his arms tight
around the 24 year old reality star
i love it and if all that wasn't sweet
enough the vid also gives fans a glimpse
at a few precious family moments like
when stormy told her grandma kris jenner
the happy baby news
what do you have for lovie
what is this
are you pregnant lovey it's the best you
know they they're the kids bring such
joy you know and it makes everything
worth it and then when your kids your
babies have babies it's magic and when
stormy joined her famous parents for
their first trip to the doctor's office
are you ready to go to mommy's doctor
yeah
a source previously told et that stormy
is thrilled to be a big sister and in
the vlog she makes it pretty clear she's
pumped about the new gig we're just so
excited that stormy is going to be a big
sister
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so she was a little shy at the mic
during the baby shower
but stormy wasn't shy about giving her
baby brother all the kisses while he was
still in her mommy's tummy
[Music]
she even made some art for her baby bros
nursery
she's the cool one
[Music]
and get this while their son was born
february 2nd he was due on stormy's
birthday february 1st this baby
and you have the same due date
yeah so the you and the baby could have
the same birthday okay february 1st
you okay with that
yes
okay bye
of course the adorbs family video comes
after kylie kept it real about that
postpartum life last week
i just want to say
to my postpartum moms that postpartum
has not been easy it's not easy mentally
physically
spiritually
it's just
crazy and yeah i didn't want to just get
back to life without saying that and she
sent a little message of encouragement
to all those new moms out there going
through it too
it's okay
not to be okay once
i realized that i was putting some
pressure on myself and i just keep
reminding myself i made a whole human
beautiful healthy boy
and we have to stop putting pressure on
ourselves to
be back not even physically just
mentally
after
after birth so yeah
just sending some love
love you guys
[Music]
you